[Music]
foreign
this week Sky News has opened the
Westminster accounts and been looking
for answers on who funds our politics
there doesn't seem to be anybody here
we're trying to get in touch with people
from npm connect
yesterday we finally got some answers
from MPS about donations from companies
that offer few details about themselves
now the head of a key ethics Watchdog
has intervened telling us an overhaul is
needed when MPS take money from
companies do you think that they ought
to do basic due diligence so they can
say who ultimately within the company is
behind the donation and perhaps why
they're giving the money when the short
answer that is yeah yes they should when
they're not currently required to uh
under the rules but if that money you'd
say come through a political part of
that political party had to do a degree
of of due diligence and I think it won't
be unreasonable to put together some
guidelines for members of parliament to
be able to answer some just very basic
questions some MPS worry voters see big
numbers and pound signs and think the
worst but Lord pickles welcomed our
searchable tool the moment is a bit
hodgepodge and you have to go out of
your way I mean the great thing in terms
of what you put together is all in one
place one of the biggest things to come
out of the Westminster account so far is
just how hard it is to find out basic
details about some companies that give
to MPS and that's why the intervention
by Eric pickles Lord pickles is so
interesting and important today he says
that MPS must be able to provide a named
individual as being behind a donation
even if it comes from a company that's a
very big change from what happens at the
moment more calls to curb the outside
earnings of figures like Boris Johnson
who can make hundreds of thousands of
pounds for a single speech the liberal
Democrat Party leader unimpressed
I would suggest that MPS would need to
seriously look at themselves for being
paid 300 000 pounds for an hour's speech
engagement and then the rules need to be
tightened up on that one reason I really
welcome what you're doing with toy toys
is I want to have that debate again I
want to clean up British politics I want
this transparency I want title rules and
I want to reform uh party Finance Shadow
foreign secretary David Lammy has had
more outside sources of income than any
other MP all transparent and within the
rules but still mean he has earned
around a hundred thousand pounds for
speaking and training engagements since
December 2019. Labor's Deputy leader
told Beth Rigby an Ethics commission
should rule if MPS should do this in
future it's not just about how much you
earn from it it's actually about how
does that contribute to your job as an
MP and to public Life as a politician
and you know making huge amounts of
money
um off you know things that don't
actually represent your constituents I
think is a different matter but I don't
think it's for me to decide that this is
why we set up a independent ethics
commission that looks at these things
[Music]
are MPS properly representing
constituents the issue at the heart of
the Westminster account tomorrow how
money Works in Parliament Sam coat Sky
News